[Music]
welcome everybody well we are just three
days away from the biggest and most
emotional event of the year the one love
Manchester concert for the victims of
the terror attack tickets reportedly
sold out in just six minutes more acts
have just been added in our Carly Steele
is on the ground in England with more
today crews set up the stage at Emirates
Old Trafford in Manchester and security
is already in place you can see warning
signs are posted and personnel are
screening those who enter and while the
Black Eyed Peas have officially joined
the lineup we've learned that four gate
will not be here Berg is no longer a
full-time member of the group a source
tells ET she is still in the family but
is focusing on her solo project
and today more British acts were
confirmed girl group Little Mix and
singer Robbie Williams will perform the
former take that fun man joining his old
band a fitting reunion for a city still
feeling take that was was recruited
because they are a Manchester band and
we've learned that among the attack
survivors attending Sunday's benefit are
several members of this local school
choir who will take the stage with
ariana grande during the show we did get
outside and we want to do as much as we
can to people that didn't cuz I give you
I can't imagine what it feels like for
the families of those who lost their
loved ones in an interview the air today
on good morning Britain John Legend
reached out to families of the 22 killed
including the parents of 15 year-old
Olivia Campbell I have a young daughter
now but the idea of having to bury one
of your children's I can't even bear the
thought of it do it out yes Olivia was a
John Legend fan and this week he sent
her mom and dad a message I was so moved
by your daughter's performance of the
song any love that we can send you we
want to send you right now along with
raising spirits the concert is also
raising money for the victims of the
terror attack they've already brought in
nearly eight million dollars
you
you